كلما اقتربت المهله من نهايتها زادت حده
التوتر بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وخصومه الجمهوريين بشان ازمه سقف الدين
بيض الذي اضطرته الازمه الى اختصار جولته
الاسيويه لم يستطع انتظار العوده الى
واشنطن فارسل تحذيره من اليابان باللجوء
الى خيارات دستوريه تتجاوز الكونجرس مركز
امريكا لم ولن تتخلف عن سداد ديونها
التقيت مع زعماء الكونجرس قبل سفر واتفقنا
على انه لا بديل عن التوصل للاتفاق
يقول الديمقراطيون انما يقوم به
الجمهوريون من ربط بين خفض الانفاق ورفع
سقف الدين مساومه حزبيه وابتزاز سياسي في
مساله تتعلق بالامن القومي الامريكي
والامساك بالاقتصاد العالمي كله
رهينه لجشائهم
بينما يرد الجمهوريون وعلى راسهم رئيس
مجلس النواب كيفن ماكارسي بان ميزانيه
الرئيس تقترح انفاق اموال اكثر مما انفقته
اداره الجمهوريين خلال وباء كورونا
لا يمكننا الاستمرار في الاقتراض من الصين
والاعتماد عليها وخلق المزيد من التضخم لا
اعتقد انه من التطرف القول انه يجب ان
ننفق اقل مما انفقناه هذا العام
ربما لا تكون المره الاولى التي يتصادم
فيها الخصمان الديمقراطي والجمهوري خصوصا
مع بدء السباق نحو البيت الابيض لكنها
ربما تكون الاولى ان لم يتم التوصل الى حل
التي تعجز فيها الولايات المتحده عن سداد
ديونها ما يفتح الباب امام سيناريوهات
كارثيه وفقا لمحللين
عن سداد ديونها من قبل ومن التداعيات
السياسيه لذلك عدم ادراك الشعب الامريكي
خطوره هذا الامر
وتداعياته حيث سترتفع اسعار الفائده الى
مستويات قياسيه وسيؤثر هذا على حياه
الجميع كما سيتضرر النظام المالي العالمي
كله
يبدو الرئيس بايدن كمن يتجرع السم فتجاوز
الكونغرس لحل ازمه سقف الدين يهدد بازمه
دستوريه اخرى غير مسبوقه ولا تقل خطوره عن
ازمه التخلف عن سداد الديون يدرك
الجمهوريون ذلك ويواصلون تمترسهم واستمع
خوف متزايده من ان هذا الخلاف قد يجر
البلاد ومعها الاقتصاد العالمي كله الى
هويه حقيقيه لا تحمد عقباها عبد الفتاح
فايد الجزيره واشنط